All right, good afternoon everyone and welcome
to the webinar about Revised Release Plan
for the NCBI API keys.
My name is Eric Sayers and I will be guiding
you through updates about this.
Again at the bottom there is a link at https://go.usa.gov/xQBQJ
, it provides a direct link to the materials
and ultimately to the Q&A.
All right.
With that we will get started.
One plug I would like to make before we get
into the webinar is EDirect Office hours today
at 2:30 PM.
If you would like to learn more about EDirect,
ask questions, give comments, the URL is there,
nnlm.gov/class/EDirect-office-hours/8301.
This is part of an ongoing training program
that NLM is providing for EDirect.
And EDirect is a UNIX interface to the E-utilities
API.
If you work on the command line this is a
great tool you might want to check out.
To see how it might be useful for you.
That's at 2:30 PM today.
All right, moving forward.
What we would like to do today is talk a little
bit about some updates to our plans for API
keys , and we have talked about this a couple
of times in the past, just to update you on
where we are now.
In November we did a couple of webinars about
API keys , introducing the idea of them and
updating you on the plans but this is the
third installment of that series.
I will talk to you about what's happening
at the moment, and what we see happening going
forward.
I will do a quick review for those that haven't
attended the other webinars.
And if you haven't, please check them out
and it will give you some good background
material about what we are talking about today.
But I will try to catch you up in terms of
where we are with a little review.
I will talk about the sandbox environment
we have released, that for developers should
be useful to you.
As well as upcoming testing periods and how
those will work.
And going ultimately to full release of the
keys.
What is happening.
The thing that is really happening we are
getting feedback from people, exactly what
we want.
To hear from you about what is useful to you
and what you're doing with the API and how
we can help you do what you are doing better.
How we can understand your needs.
We have had a number of conversations about
that and we are continuing to have conversations.
Please engage us in those conversations moving
forward, that's helping us understand how
we can help you.
As a result of that, we are not honoring the
May 1 release date.
In November we targeted May 1, which is a
few days away, as the date when the API keys
would be going fully live.
We will not be.
That date has been pushed back to no earlier
than September 1.
So relax, you have time, you have the summer
to get ready for this . we will let you know
well in advance if that date changes.
It will not be before September 1, 2018, when
the keys go live.
What we have done is create a sandbox that
is active today.
It has been active for a little bit, active
now, where the keys are always active.
I will talk more about that in a few minutes.
That's a good simulation of what production
will be like.
Very likely in the fall.
And we will be having some test periods, no
more than about one hour, on production over
the coming weeks, months, where the keys will
become active.
This is a chance to test code in the actual
production environment.
And also to check things that maybe we are
not aware of, or you are aware of that might
be affected by the upcoming keys.
A quick review of what we are talking about
in terms of the API's being affected . These
are the E-utilities only.
No blast APIs, no other APIs are affected.
The E-utilities are the Entrez APIs esummary,
efetch, elink and epost.
These are things you use to do searches in
PubMed, or gene or nucleotide, to get esummary
doc sums, fasta, abstracts, citation formats,
and various types of literature and sequence
data.
Those of the APIs you need to be concerned
about.
If you are using them, then you need to pay
attention, if using blast APIs, it's not something
relevant at the moment.
What are keys?
A API keys is a unique string.
A string that will be added to the URL request.
The string identifies you to the API.
It needs to be included in every API request
you make.
These API keys are attached to a NCBI account
. Some of you may know as a My NCBI account.
But one account can have a single API key.
One of the big reasons we are doing this is
we want the API to be more stable and reliable
to you.
And having these keys helps us make that happen,
by being better able to monitor and regulate
the amount of traffic that comes into the
services.
We would love to have infinite capacity and
we don't.
No one does.
But to make it seem as this we have capacity
to meet your needs, this is a way for us to
help regulate that, to help you regulate it
to the point it can work for you as well as
possible.
So how do you get a key?
A reminder, you go to my NCBI , or a NCBI
account.
Find the link in the upper right-hand corner
of the NCBI pages.
And sign in . You can create an account if
you don't already have one.
If you have an account, please use that.
If you'd like to create a new account for
software, that is fine.
There is a button under API key management
where you can create an API key.
It will put it on the screen, copy it.
How do you use the key?
Very simple.
You assign it to the parameter api_key.
You put that parameter in any, all of your
E-utilities requests . I'm showing you the
einfo, and esearch for example, put api_key
equals and whatever the key is.
If you are an EDirect user, there is an environmental
variable named NCBI_API_KEY.
EDirect will automatically attach your API
key to all outgoing requests.
If you want to get a new key you can, but
the old key dies immediately.
You can only have one key per NCBI account
. If you think somebody else has got it and
you are concerned about it, whatever reason,
you're tired of it you can get rid of it.
When you replacement it the other one goes
away immediately, no longer active.
I want to say a word before I start talking
about rates.
How we define rates.
What we will be talking about is key setting
rate limits on the number of requests coming
in.
If you get an error, about the rates, I am
showing at the top of the slide, and error
text saying the API rate limit is exceeded,
and a count meaning the number of requests
that we saw in a particular second.
The important thing for people to realize,
we are looking at a one second window and
we care about when the requests were received
at NCBI, not execution time . What we really
care about is the fact that you started more
than your limit of requests in a one second
window.
In the bottom you see a lot of requests that
are taking a number of seconds.
But there is no time during that activity
where more than three request are being received
per second.
For example if your limit was three.
That's one of the default limits.
That's how the rates are being defined.
There is a new sandbox that we have.
The new sandbox is an environment where the
keys will be active permanently.
And so this is a great place to go to test.
You can hit this.
What is different about this for those familiar
with the API, the URL is api dot NCBI dot
NLM dot gov/eutils.
Not www or eutils dot ncbi.
The keys will always be active there.
This will simulate production.
It is active now and you can start testing
now.
At the bottom of the slide I've put example
URLs.
If I want to do a esearch I just do api.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/eutils.fcgi?
then whatever you are doing just change the
base URL to API dot NCBI slash eutils.
What happens in the sandbox.
If you've been it one of the previous webinars
you will have heard this.
This is the behavior that happens now in the
sandbox and will happen when we go live in
full production.
If you don't have a key, let's start there.
If you don't have a key the limit is three
requests per second for each individual IP.
What I am showing is three IP addresses.
The first one two requests per second, that
is fine, no key.
The second one has five requests per second,
that would cause an error.
You will get an error when you get those back.
And one and a half request per second, no
problem.
As long as you are below 3 requests per second
for any 1 second moving window, you are fine.
What happens to those requests that receive
an error, they are not processed.
You are not blocked, there's nothing like
that happening.
Once the second window passes and you go beneath
the rate limit, you will get access again,
immediately.
The requests will start working.
What you will see in your data is gaps.
Where you're not getting dated back.
Why am I not getting data back?
Because you are momentarily you are blocked,
if I want to say it that way, by the rate
limit.
Keep in mind this is not like the IP getting
blocked or anything like that.
It is instantaneous, once the rates go below
the limit, you are live and well.
What happens if you have an IP that two people
are sharing, or multiple people share.
What happens here is we have two people sharing
the same IP.
One is doing two request per second and one
is doing five, both get affected.
Because it is by the IP.
You have multiple users in the same IP, and
one actor over three request per second, everyone
is affected.
That could be a potential issue.
If you have a lot of people behind a firewall,
whatever it might be.
It depends on the IP, if there is no key.
That's important to remember.
If you have a key.
Now I have several scenarios where there is
a key present.
In this case the first two people have the
same IP address, but two different keys.
The first guy has this key, AB23.
He is under 10 requests per second.
With the key the default limit goes from 3
to 10.
As long as you don't exceed 10 request per
second with the key, you are fine.
So seven is cool.
His friend is doing 15 requests per second.
He will get errors.
A different key.
And the third guy at a different IP address,
it doesn't matter.
Four request per second, he has a different
key.
My point here is it's about the key, not the
IP address.
It doesn't matter how many people share the
IP address, it only matters what key you have
and how many requests are coming in on that
particular key.
For example, here we have a case where we
are mixing.
Some people have a key and some people don't
have a key.
What happens?
Everyone is on the same IP address.
The first guy has a key.
Less than 10, he is fine.
The second guy has a different key. he's at
15, he gets errors.
And the third guy no key.
It looks at the IP.
That IP is getting seven, +15, equals 22 plus
2 equals 24 request per second, so he gets
errors.
This hopefully illustrates to you the problems
you can have if you have a lot of people using
the same IP.
The best approach is each person having their
own key.
That key determines the rate.
If you have people using the same key we see
the sum of the rate from that same key.
One person may get errors, and if they get
errors, everyone using that key will get errors.
It is attached to the key.
That is an issue if you're using a distributed
scenario where multiple people are using the
same key.
If one of them gets above the threshold, then
they all have errors.
To review quickly, the situation is if you
don't have a key, any IP address that posts
more than the limit will be affected, they
will get errors.
It is about IP if there is no key.
If there is a key, it is about the key.
So any key that posts more than 10 or whatever
the limit is, will receive errors.
That is the real bottom line.
If you don't have a key ts about the IP address,
if you do have a key it's about whoever is
using that key however many people are using
that key .
That is what's going to be happening in the
sandbox.
That happens now, so you can begin testing
that now.
If you have code you want to test, shoot it
to us and see what happens.
Verify it is working.
The testing periods will happen in production.
We don't yet have a schedule of these but
I will be publicizing them on utilities-announce
and on social media.
If you haven't signed up for utilities-announce,
please do.
I will have a link at the end of the presentation
that will give you access.
Pay attention to the twitter feed, the blog,
we will talk about it there.
And the behavior of production during the
test periods will be identical to the sandbox
now.
This is a way of checking production code,
also a way for us to see what breaks.
Right.
A brief period where we can make sure we are
aware of things, you are aware of things that
are affected by this.
We will give you warning about when these
will be happening so you can plan for it.
It will be no more than an hour and will occur
at different times in the day.
People use the api 24 seven, we want to make
sure we are getting everybody.
Full release.
After we do a few of these testing periods
we will publicize the date for full release
and give you at least three months notice
as to when that will be.
Right now we are saying it will not be before
September 1.
If it moves further back we will let you know
with at least three months notice.
That means all keys will become active.
We would like to also advise you, we have
a couple of questions about this we have gotten.
Please continue to use tool an email if you're
using them.
If you are not using them please begin using
them.
It does not affect your key in any way.
Completely separate from the key, however
they help us help you by identifying the software
package that is attached to the request.
A number of you have expressed interest in
having distributed keys so one software package
may have multiple keys.
The key itself will not identify the software
package, &tool does.
So if you need us to help you understand activity
with software, and what we are seeing, then
&tool is required.
And then &email is the contact information
for the developer , so we can contact you
about that.
It should not be a customer contact.
It should be a developer contact so we can
talk directly to whoever is monitoring it
and presiding over the code base.
So we can help you deliver quality services
to your users.
So, that is basically what I want to say today.
I want to encourage you to stay tuned on the
social media.
There is the Learn page if we do give more
webinars.
We don't have more plans now but if we have
to give additional ones we will publicize
them there.
Also on social media.
And the link I was promising, please subscribe
to utilities-announce.
When you get the slides you can just click
there and go to the link.
It's the www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov slash mailman
slash listinfo slash utilities-announce.
You are not going to get spammed, only updates.
We try to respect your time and your inbox.
If it's important we will send things there.
If you have questions please write to info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
Also I'll invite you to ask us about negotiating
higher rate keys than 10.
As we have talked about in previous webinars,
if you think you will need a higher rate than
10 per second, we can talk with you about
adjusting it upward.
If you would like to engage us in such a conversation,
we are happy to do that, just write to info
and we can follow up.
All right.
That's what I had to say today.
I will turn it over to Peter Cooperto see
what questions we have.
[Peter] Thank you Eric.
There are a number of questions.
Some I have addressed and some of them I don't
know the answer to.
I will let you take a shot.
There is a question, the first one actually
is about this question of reset time.
Talking about a particular thing called the
X rate limit reset time, indicating when the
current window ends.
The window is one second so I don't quite
know I understand the question.
Can you address that?
[Eric] I am not sure I would understand the
full context there.
If you want to talk to us more about that,
just write to info and we will talk to you
more.
What I can say is the way, again we determine
the rates, is based on the moving one second
window.
We monitor the key or the IP address, and
if we see incoming requests in a given one
second window that exceeds the rate limit,
if your rate is three and we see more than
three request starts in the one second window,
then you will get an error.
Until that rate in the moving one second window
drops below three.
That is basically what I can say.
If you have other questions about that, email
and we can follow up.
[Peter] A couple of questions.
You addressed them in the talk but I thought
it would be worth pointing out again.
Somebody did ask about the email and tool
parameter.
It's not required but very important that
you include that.
So we can get in touch with you.
Another one, are the response rates given
the headers?
I think we discovered that they are given
in the headers.
[Eric] Thank you for pointing that out that
I should've mentioned it.
You should be expecting status 429.
Any error you get should give you a 429, that's
what we have found in our own test.
We are pretty confident that people are seeing
those.
It's a little snippet in the header.
You should be able to look for a 429.
And the rate is in the error message.
The integer you will see at the end of that
data blob you get back is the rate that we
observed.
On the slide it was 11 I believe, like 1 more
than 10.
That's what we observed.
[Peter] Another good question is about many
of the different Perl modules available.
There is one that he cites, a bio eutilities,
bio db utilities.
He says it hasn't been updated to support
the API keys.
Have we reached out to the developers.
I don't think we have.
[Eric] Thank you for the question.
A good point.
I don't know that we have specifically reached
out to organizations like that.
We often are in contact with them in any case.
It's a question honestly for them in terms
of what they would like to support.
Certainly one approach they could do is have
more support for keys in there and they may
choose to do that.
They may choose to have developers solve that
problem on their own.
I don't have any direct information from them,
but thank you for that.
It is certainly possible we can get in touch
with them for clarity.
[Peter] Okay, another question, somebody asked
can I make sure no key will be used for distributed
service.
I think the answer is we can't be sure it
won't be used that way.
Every user on a distrubuted service should
have their own key.
[Eric] This is a fairly common class of questions.
A number of software developers will distribute
their code base.
Basically if you're distributing software
that way, it is good to have a key, right,
for the individual customers if you think
the use cases the customers have will drive
their use over three request for second.
It really depends on the nature of your software
and the number of requests you tend to fire.
That a typical customer would tend to fire.
It's a judgement call on your part.
If you'd like to talk with us about strategies,
that is a lot of the kind of conversations
we have been having with software developers.
We are happy to engage in those.
One of the things you can think about is perhaps
having a default key, that would cover most
of your customers.
We can set a rate that would cover most cases.
You may have some customers that are very
heavy users.
And you know that.
We may be able to give them particular keys.
These are the kinds of things we can talk
about.
It really just depends a lot on the nature
of your software, how you distribute it, and
the manner in which you access the utility
API.
How many request are you making.
There are ways to talk to you that can help
you reduce the number of request that you
need to make.
That's why having these conversations is important,
to find out what would be helpful for your
customers.
[Peter] Here is a somewhat philosophical perhaps
question.
The API key is only there to help NCBI monitor
the request per second ? It's on our personal
side to adapt our scripts to handle this request
limitation.
You want to talk about why we are doing this?
[Eric] A number of topics there we can talked
about.
One topic is, why do you want to do the keys
at all.
It comes back to a general part of our mission,
as the national Library of medicine, providing
free services to the public.
Free does not mean unregulated.
Meaning we have had many cases in the past
where particular small number of users, essentially
created denial of service attack on our servers
because of heavy use.
Our mission is to relay the services to the
public so we have to do whatever we can to
make sure the public has access 24/7.
That basically means preventing excessively
high use for any of the services.
Whatever it might be.
The keys help us do that.
The keys also help you.
I understand from some perspectives it might
be hard to see that.
The keys help you because it helps us make
the services more reliable.
They are less vulnerable to these kinds of
attacks.
Once the attacks happen you will not be able
to get to us.
If you have processes that are automated and
your customers depend on those processes,
we want it to be up to you.
Preventing these kinds of spikes, and problematic
activity, allows us to have the services up
more often than not.
It also allows us to inform you as developers
about what is happening with your software.
And to alert you earlier to problems we are
seeing.
If people are abusing your software, or providing
sets of request to us that are harmful, to
our ability to provide services to the public,
it helps us help you understand what's happening
and correct those issues.
So at the moment, the way we are rolling keys
out, yes, as you point out, it kind of is
on you to think about what your rates are.
As we explore this further there may be other
ways that we can modify and extend, perhaps
strengthen the way the keys work, to make
them more flexible.
We are certainly interested in input from
the community about how that will happen.
We have had some discussions about that already.
So we are very open to having your thoughts
and suggestions about ways in which the services
can be more adaptable to your needs.
This is where we are currently.
[Peter] Another, several questions that I
don't think we will have time to get to all
of them.
If we don't, we will answer them in a Q&A
document.
I will put that on the FTP site and you can
look at those .
One is about being blocked.
If we continue to exceed the rate will we
be blocked?
The answer to that I think is no.
One of the points is that you can't, we are
throttling you so you can't actually do damage.
[Eric] It's an important question for those
who are experienced users of the API who may
have been blocked in the past.
We do have a policy by which we will block
access to an IP or a set of IPs, if we observe
extraordinarily high rates.
And the manifestation of such a block is to
have no ability to reach our servers.
On the web you will see a black screen that
clearly indicates you have been prevented
access with instructions for how to proceed
to restore access.
The API keys have nothing to do with that
process at all.
The API keys are actually a way to help us
prevent that.
We don't want to be doing that.
We want people to have access.
What happens with the keys as Peter indicated,
as I tried to indicate, is an instantaneous
and very temporary cessation of service for
a particular IP or API key that is giving
us a high number of requests.
The manifestation again, of the rate being
exceeded, because I don't want to use the
term blocked because you aren't, is simply
those individual request will receive an error
message until the rate drops below the threshold.
So you will just see gaps in data, data returns
that are unusually small because all they
will receive is the error message.
That's what you will see as a user.
Or if you are a web user are a user of a third-party
app on top of the API, you won't get data
back for the periods when the rates are high.
We don't memorize that, there is no recording
of that activity.
You will get an error until the rates go down
again.
There is no blocking happening.
There is no permanent memory of any of that.
It's just instantaneous responses.
[Peter] Okay, that is all we have time for.
As I said if there's additional questions
we didn't address, and all of the questions
we did address, we will put in the document.
I would like to thank everybody for coming
and thank you Eric for presenting.
We will see you next time.